So there's a great
line that says
that sex is a disappointing
answer to life's riddle
and that love is ultimately
a religious problem.
What we hope to get with love is
what we failed to get with God.
Once we dispensed with God,
or once Nietzsche told us
that God is dead, we needed
something else to believe in.
And so now we deify the other.
When in love, they
are like the wind.
They are our salvation.
She becomes the sun.
What we really hope to gain
from love is completion.
It's transcendence.
It's immortality now.
It's stepping off
that people mover
that's carrying everyone
else towards death.
It's transcending
the human condition.
By merging with an
incarnation of the divine,
we might be saved too.
Ultimately when we fall
in love, it's a prayer.
It's a sacrifice.
We give ourselves and hope
that this beam of light
will save us from
our animal condition.
We can dispense from
being gods with anuses
and being just gods.
You know, the whole purpose
of the human condition
is to leave our animality behind
and become the symbolic beings,
the self-creating
beings that we are,
this recursive self-aware,
self-creating consciousness
that is constantly
scripting, and rewriting,
and editing its own
subjective unfolding as mind,
mind constantly trumping matter.
We can sense the divine
within ourselves.
We see the divine within
ourselves, the namaste.
And we just reach out and
try to get it from the other.
And perhaps the impulse to
find salvation in the other
is a mistake.
And perhaps the answer is
in our creativity instead.
I don't know, just a thought.